das sind die besten Pommes die du zu
Hause zubereiten kannst außen knusprig
und innen fluffig probieren wir
selfemate und so gut wir starten mit
einer mehligigen Kartoffel die schneide
ich einfach so in ich sag mal Steakhouse
Fries denn wir wollen einen garverlauf
haben ganz wichtig außen knusprig innen
schön weich die Kartoffelstifte geben
wir jetzt in Wasser und lassen sie dort
über Nacht einweichen am nächsten Tag
sieht man richtig dass das Wasser trüb
geworden ist weil die Stärke von den
Kartoffeln ausgetreten ist und so haben
wir schon mal die halbe Miete für eine
perfekt knusprige Pommes es ist keine
gute Idee Wasser in die frituse zu tun
deshalb schauen sie wirklich trocken
sind wenn sie wirklich gut trocken sind
sehen sie irgendwann so aus und man kann
auch schon den wichtigsten Schritt
machen und zwar das vorfrittieren nicht
bei voller Temperatur sondern einfach
reinschmeißen bei 120° und ab ins Öl und
die Pommes sind fertig wenn ihr sie so
Piepsen hört nach ungefähr 5 Minuten die
Pommes habe ich dann abgetrocknet und in
den Gefrierschrank getan jetzt sind sie
schön kalt und trocken und ab in die
frituse bei 180° ungefähr 10 Minuten
später sind die Pommes goldbraun und
fertig rausgeholt zu werden Ketchup und
Mayo dürfen natürlich nicht fehlen und
fertig sind sie